BRING US ANY BREAKING NEWS AS
YOU GET IT.
>> John: BACK NOW TO OUR TOP
STORY.
THE GROWING CALLS FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN THE
INVESTIGATION AT THE ORIGINS OF
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
DAVID ASHER JOINS US NOW.
HE IS A FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WHO LED A PROBE INTO
THE PANDEMIC UNDER FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
JUST AS AT THIS UP FOR THE FOLKS
AT HOME, THIS IS THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WE WERE
REPORTING ON YESTERDAY THAT WAS
SHUT DOWN IN THE SPRING BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
YOU LEFT THAT IN INVESTIGATION
IN
JANUARY OR SO.
WHAT WAS AT INVESTIGATION
FINDING?
>> WE WERE FINDING THAT DESPITE
THE CLAIMS ARE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF HOW THE THE AND DR. FAUCI DEN
ORGANIZATION, THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTED A
NATURAL ZOO ONE ATTIC EVOLUTION
OR SOURCE OF COVID-19.
I CAME INTO AN INVESTIGATION
DOING A COMPLIANT SUPPORT AND
RELATED TO THE BIO WEAPON TREATY
AND WE SAID, "LET’S LOOK AT THIS
AND UP BOTH SOURCES OF EVIDENCE.
LET’S SEE IF IT CAME OUT OF
NATURE OR DID IT COME OUT OF A
LAB?
"THE DATA DISPROPORTIONATELY
STACKED UP AS WE INVESTIGATED
THAT WAS COMING OUT OF A LAB OR
SOME SUPERNATURAL SOURCE.
>> John: AT THAT POINT IN
TIME, THE PERSON WAS OVERSEEING
THIS, CHRIS FORD, YOU’RE SAYING
HE DIDN’T WANT TO ENTERTAIN THIS
IDEA?
QUESTION MARKS PEACOAT NO.
HE SEEMED DISINTERESTED.
HE SAID HOW DO WE KNOW WHERE IT
CAME OUT OF AND WHAT LAB?
VERY RARELY IN MY LIFE OF
GOVERNMENT HAVE I ENCOUNTERED
ANYONE WHO IS MORE OF A NEGATIVE
AND LESS OF A BUREAUCRAT THE NAP
THAT INDIVIDUAL.
I VERY RARELY SAY I ENCOUNTERED
DISGRACEFUL BEHAVIOR AND
GOVERNMENT BUT I DID IN THIS
OCCASION.
>> John: YOU SAY THAT YOU ARE
LOOKING INTO COMPLIANCE IN TERMS
OF WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION
ARMS CONTROL.
IT WAS THERE A MILITARY
COMPONENT TO THIS?
>> OF COURSE.
WE WERE TRYING TO ASSESS THE
ENTIRE BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS
PROGRAM OF CHINA AND I HAVE A
BACKGROUND IN BIOTECH
INVESTIGATION.
I CAME BACK THAT THE CONTRACTORS
AND REGULAR GOVERNMENT THAT HIDE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY MORE OR
LESS.
I KNOW A LOT ABOUT SYNTHETIC
BIOLOGY AND I RAPIDLY ZEROED IN
ON THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF
VIROLOGY BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
CENTER OF OUR EPICENTER OF
BIOLOGY IN THE PEOPLE’S REPUBLIC
OF CHINA.
THEY WERE UP TO SOME VERY HAIRY
STUFF.
>> John: OF WHAT YOU BELIEVE
TO THE INTELLIGENCE THAT YOUR
TAX FORCE GATHERED THAT THE
CHINESE WERE DOING AND RETURN TO
REGARDS TO CORONAVIRUS.
DUMB?
>> AS MEMBER’S OF THE BIOLOGICAL
WEAPONS CONVENTION, THEY WERE
ENGAGED IN CORONAVIRUS RESEARCH
AND THEN IN 2016 AND THEY STOP
DECLARING THAT AND THIS IS FOR
BIO DEFENSE PURPOSES.
WHY DID THEY STOP DECLARING IT?
AS WE UNVEILED IT AND I IN OUR
DECLASSIFIED STATEMENT, WITH THE
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS OBVIOUSLY WAS
PRESENT.
>> John: DR. FAUCI HAS
MAINTAINED FROM THE NIH THAT
AMERICAN MONEY WAS NOT USED TAKE
FUND GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
AT WUHAN.
YOU SUGGESTED THAT THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN RESEARCH THERE AT
THAT LABORATORY.
DID YOU FIND ANYTHING TO CONNECT
THE DOTS BETWEEN NIH FUNDING AND
WHAT WAS GOING ON AT THE LAB?
>> I WASN’T INVOLVED IN
RESEARCHING THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT’S INVOLVEMENT IN
RESEARCH BUT LOOKING AT THE
SHINY SIDE OF THIS, THE CHINESE
MOST CERTAINLY FELT THAT NIH WAS
SUPPORTING THIS.
THE CORONAVIRUS FACTORS WERE
RADICALLY UNNATURAL AND THEY
WERE NOT SIMILAR TO ANYTHING
THAT OCCURRED NATURALLY IN
EVOLUTION.
IN FACT, I HAD BIASED TACTICIANS
CALCULATE THE ODDS AND IT
WAS ONE IN 13 MILLION.
THEY THEN REVISE IT TO ONE AND
13 BILLION.
TO SAY THIS CAME OUT OF A ZOO
ONE ATTIC SITUATION IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> John: VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE
I HAVE A FEW SECONDS HERE, WHEN
ALL IS SAID AND DONE, WHAT YOU
BELIEVE THIS INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE WILL FIND AND
CONCLUDE?
>> I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME.
I THINK THEY FINALLY GOT THEIR
HEADS AROUND THIS AND I THINK
THEY WILL FIND A LOT.
WHETHER THEY WILL SEE MUCH AS A
DIFFERENT MATTER.
WE MADE A BIG EFFORT UNDER
SECRETARY POMPEO’S DIRECTION TO
DECLASSIFY INFORMATION.
I HOPE THAT CONGRESS BIPARTISAN
LAY DEMANDS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOES THE SAME.
>> John: WE WILL SEE WHERE